are you still uh are you still in a
relationship are you single what's going
on yeah yeah I'm still in a relationship
you've kind of kicked back from like
posting your girl too much because
before I feel like you were out there
with it yeah is there a reason like why
like
um
it's just too personal yeah I don't want
people in my business yeah let them let
them listen to the [__] album if they
want to know your business y'all listen
to not sure if you want if you want to
hear about Nazareth listen to Nigeria
it's a pretty wild first name I love it
yeah I don't know where the [__] my mom
got that from what I was about to say is
that a one of one type of first name
yeah you don't anymore I know my
siblings name so please tell me Niger
and menajah
oh she a Nicki Minaj fan nah hell no yes
she is actually yeah yeah she is but I
thought you meant like Nicki Minaj
feeling like this is that where she got
it from nah menajah manager okay
yeah like Tracy so Tracy sounds like a
90s Bay Area rapper or something like
Dre hyphen C you know from Oakland or
something yeah Tracy sounds like he'd
have a song with like spice one or
something all right you ready for the
other one okay a shot of you ashadia
yeah yo [__] lit yeah bro I don't
know where the [__] these names like I
have a shot of your best tequila yeah
can I have a shot of your best tequila
you feel me yeah it's like that you know
see Yo shout out to your mom she's
[__] lit she was drunk next time I
have a kid I'm gonna call you I'm gonna
say I need I need your mom to make my
mom to name my kid yo it'll be some wild
[__] yeah nah yeah you don't want that
though bro I don't know what my mom was
thinking you know people be trying to be
different though shout out to her I love
her mom if you see this interview is
your mama very proud of you yes my mom
is very proud of me have you ever had
your mom call you about some Like lyrics
and like what the [__] is this yeah oh
yeah yeah hell yeah on the album I said
something about a dude she was dating oh
what'd you say
um the new album that's coming out yeah
I thought I was talking about this guy
named Terence who uh
man he was trying to he was trying to
get with my mom and I I guess it kind of
didn't work and he put us out we was
homeless he kicked y'all out kicked us
out it was homeless here she [__] my
mom
and it didn't and when you were a kid
yeah Terence I mean but they grown
though ain't no telling what happened
she probably I don't know you're on here
yeah but still to kill me kids out you
know like you gotta go the kids could
stay he kick us off you gotta get the
[__] out of here he kicked us out damn
so what I wonder what Terence is doing
nowadays yeah I wonder what Terence is
doing so what did Mom be like yeah what
the [__] I don't know how my mama feel
about me talk about this hey Mom
well you're talking about it on the
[__] house my phone let me call my
mom
let me let me let me call my mom real
quick bring my phone got it we gotta
call Mom Dukes again call Mom and let's
figure out what happened with Tim let's
figure out unplug it what was going to
be the name of the next kid had she had
one all right let's call him your mom's
gonna answer right yeah of course my mom
loved me
that's a serious case on your phone I
respect it Bottega that's just the type
of case yeah
I'm chilling Ma
on you see she loved me I told you hey
Mom what happened we're in the middle of
an interview with your son
it's Kevin
um
you have a special talent of naming your
children amazing names
yes you did well you should
yeah okay you should write a baby name
book uh too what happened with you and
Terence
all right listen listen you don't gotta
you don't you listen hold on you don't
gotta tell him what but listen am I okay
to talk about this on the interview
okay nothing bad happened all right
oh yes he was a blessing he's gonna see
this interview and get so much Play
Chance was a great guy
from being a stranger to being an
amazing friend who did something all
right God bless
hey hey hey baby hey hey lay you to
death hey
I ain't gonna go say nothing where are
you on you good
I'm trying to figure out what you want
hey hey hey uh I'm gonna call you later
and I'll tell you
I love you bye Mom love you love you I
love you nothing uh
um
hey not listen uh when I was a little
bit younger Mike couldn't do that but
she got to go now cause uh she's like
Terence is a great guy and he's a great
friend and he is a blessing Hey Boy
[__] know what you did I'm a home [__]
know what he did but
here